alright guys so my family the taboc
family has had a huge feud for the past
couple months I know with HIV because
the wolf doesn't know her mother and
father so we went to a wolf sanctuary
and they explicitly said no wolves can
happen she's 50% winning person so the
story that my mom and my dad told my
family was that when my dad was living
in Turkey there was a wolf and a dog
chained up in the forest near my dad's
house and he would always visit them and
one day he found a puppy just running
around free so he assumed that the wolf
and the dog had a little fun made a
puppy and now it's running around free
the Turkish people didn't want those
animals in that area so they were gonna
get rid of them but my dad offered to
take the puppy and ever since she's been
our dog my sister and I don't think
she's a wolf because the wolves that we
met at this wolf farm were huge they
can't really live indoors they have to
be outside she's tiny she has blue eyes
she just looks like a husky mix so what
I've done is I got a DNA test and I'm
gonna settle this debate forever so this
awesome company in bark sent me a little
DNA package and they're partnered with
Cornell University and smart people go
there so I trust that and I'm basically
just gonna open it up see how it works
and then secretly test my dog or wolf
dog or I don't know we'll see maybe
she's a cat our insight is the box that
I guess I'm gonna ship her DNA in I
don't even know how I'm gonna get her
DNA do I have to do like blood work and
stuff or do I just swab her mouth or
have to like send her hair in okay so
the first thing you do you go online you
act at your account then you swap them
out and then you just put it back into
this box it's already prepaid they'll
mail it back everything is it's just
super easy I'm excited to figure out my
dog that wolf or not
try it try it come here
hi girl okay so what we're gonna do
she just loves being belly up okay good
girl
oh she's doing so well
good girl shot thank you seal it tight
flip it sometimes
we did it I got my dog's DNA in here
let's go clone her no I'm kidding I'm
not gonna do that thank you
Oh oh my gosh she farted oh my gosh you
farted all right well I'm gonna mail
this and I'm gonna see what happens okay
so I'm putting it in the box
I'm gonna go put it in the mail and mail
it out okay guys so it's been a month
since I sent the DNA we're currently in
a cabin in the woods in the Poconos and
we got the results so we're gonna go
check right now guys are you ready to
see if Shay takes a wolf where is she
shot are you ready to see the results
they sent us results and her DNA
oh my god what no no guys wait guys
you're scary shot it okay here 17.8%
breed one okay 29.2% breed - okay and
she's 5.5% hi it's wolf miss what's - I
don't know what Shattuck has wolf miss
in her she actually has Wolfman
[Music]
okay let's is that cheese guts the
wolf's nuts she's not what if she just
has both flight characteristics and you
keep moving no because 1508 dog or wolf
the predicted weight is 55% pounds what
does that mean okay I'm 94 human years
yes this is so accurate okay Wow
wolf 'no see what it says most dogs have
wolf this scores of 1% or less although
we occasionally find populations and
breeds with higher scores and even some
especially unique individuals with
scores of 5% or more she's 5 percent
that means shyness and angle well this
was below 10 are almost always do that
ancient wolf genes but here it says even
some especially unique individuals
[Music]
it does a large large large Michelle
okay let's play the game you ready yes
saying what breed she is okay
Siberian house crew know he's 78
[Music]
there was no 70.8 Siberian Husky the
stupid test if you think her because
it's not to she double terrier what do
you think yes or no I guess 29.2% yes
her mother must have been a Siberian
Western her mother was great let's see
how I'm gonna see Shaikh's health real
quick
zero my risk she's clear with everything
we can find her family tree Bull Terrier
Siberian most high so let's read about
wolf enough she's an emic rapido wolf
dead Walter's that's just the word
quality of being wolfy wolfy I do think
though we can conclude that China gives
a wolf dog yes she's a she's a wolf dog
she's don't know well I think the dogs
at the sanctuary there were fifty
percent wool our wolf dogs
Sarah is a dog wolf they are moved or
that's the difference those wolf wolf
dog well that just was not in our
original back even after a DNA test my
family and I couldn't agree on what my
dog was so why don't you guys tell us
it's my dog a wolf or not
[Music]